Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. An autocrat full of self-confidence following earlier military successes and convinced that a neighbouring country has no right to exist draws up plans to invade it. In making these plans, the autocrat has no hesitation in overruling his generals. The generals, knowing what's best for them, accommodate themselves to their master's rulings. The invasion is launched. It is conducted on a wide front with multiple targets. No effort is made to win the hearts and minds of those whose lands are being occupied.
感谢收听《历史的其余部分》（The Rest Is History）。如果你想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先收听系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。一个充满自信的独裁者在早期的军事胜利之后，坚信一个邻国没有存在的权利，于是拟定了入侵该国的计划。在制定这些计划时，这位独裁者毫不犹豫地否决了他的将军们的意见。将军们深知明哲保身之道，便顺从了主子的裁决。入侵开始了。这是一场在广阔战线上拥有多重目标的进攻。人们没有做出任何努力去赢得那些土地正被占领的人们的民心。
Logistical planning proves terribly flawed. Equipment proves inadequate. Initial successes prove illusory. The invasion grinds to a halt in front of the capital city of the invaded country. The operation has not gone well. Dominic, that is a tried and tested technique, is it not, of historians writing articles in newspapers and so on, where you get two distinct, two separate events and you kind of muddle them up. Well, of course, I would never use myself, Tom. So you you're talking about so this is what tony blair 2003 is it so uh was i what was i talking about there was i talking about putin's invasion of ukraine or was i talking about hitler's invasion of russia would you say that the parallels there i mean there are parallels aren't there or are there am i am i being glib in drawing i'm not sure you said to me to me you were absolutely desperate to do this podcast because you thought there were tremendous, using all your knowledge of military history, you thought there were tremendously compelling parallels.
后勤规划被证明存在致命的缺陷。装备被证明是不够的。最初的成功不过是幻觉。入侵在被入侵国家的首都前夕陷入停顿。这次行动进展不顺利。多米尼克，这是历史学家写报纸文章等时惯用的一种屡试不爽的技巧，对吧？就是你把两个截然不同、风马牛不相及的事件混为一谈。嗯，当然，我自己是绝不会这么用的，汤姆。所以你——你在说——那么这是2003年的托尼·布莱尔吗？还是说——呃，我刚才在说什么？我是在谈论普京对乌克兰的入侵呢，还是在谈论希特勒对俄罗斯的入侵？你会说这两者之间有相似之处吗？我的意思是，它们之间确实有相似之处，对吧？还是说没有？我这样类比是不是显得有些轻率？我不确定。你对我说过，你当时绝对渴望做这期播客，因为你运用你对军事史的所有知识，认为其中存在着极具说服力的相似之处。
And I think you'd been fed that line by a member of your own family, Tom. Yes. Am I right? Yes. So, yes. A podcasting novice, clearly desperate to appear on the show. So, yeah. So fans of our sister podcast, We Have Ways of Making You Talk, will know that my brother, James Holland, and his partner, Al Murray, on the show did two brilliant episodes on Hitler's planning for Operation Barbarossa, in which certain parallels were drawn out between Hitler and his preparations for invading Russia and Putin and his preparations for invading Ukraine. Now, we don't want to major on them, but James, bro, you're out there. I thought that was brilliant.
我想你当时是被你自己的某个家庭成员灌输了这种观点，汤姆。是的。我说的对吗？是的。所以，没错。一个播客新手，显然急于在节目中露面。所以，是的。我们姐妹播客节目《我们有让你开口的方法》（We Have Ways of Making You Talk）的粉丝们会知道，我的兄弟詹姆斯·霍兰德（James Holland）和他的搭档阿尔·默里（Al Murray）在节目中就希特勒对“巴巴罗萨行动”的策划制作了两个精彩的节目，其中探讨了希特勒及其对入侵俄罗斯的准备工作与普京及其对入侵乌克兰的准备工作之间的某些相似之处。现在，我们不想过分渲染这些，但是詹姆斯，老兄，你正在收听。我觉得那期节目太精彩了。
You did mention, did you not, when we met a few days ago that there were certain parallels, and I was absolutely so excited about them that i rushed back and persuaded dominic that we should do this straight away hitler and putin before we come to that can i just open with a question so we put out questions saying we're doing uh operation barbarossa and without a doubt the best question was asked by chris who asked how close did frederick barbarossa come to establishing imperial control over the papacy? I did see that. Which is an excellent question. James, no one should have to answer that question.
你确实提到过，不是吗？我们几天前见面时，你说过其中存在某些相似之处，我当时对此感到无比兴奋，以至于我急忙赶回并说服多米尼克，我们应该立刻做这个主题——希特勒和普京。在进入正题之前，我能先以一个问题开场吗？我们发布了征集问题的通知，说我们要讲“巴巴罗萨行动”，毫无疑问，最好的问题是克里斯提出的：弗雷德里克·巴巴罗萨距离确立对教皇国的帝国控制还有多近？我确实看到那个问题了。这是一个极好的问题。詹姆斯，任何人都不应该去回答那个问题。
Well, no, but my brave old one will answer. He'll know all about that. So Frederick Barbarossa was a 12th century emperor who ended up drowning while going on the Third Crusade. And I'm guessing the reason that he gives his name to Hitler's invasion of Russia's invasion of russia is because he's kind of like the german king arthur he's supposed to have um to be in a cave in a mountain range in thuringia the untersberg no he's also supposed to be in the untersberg which is the view that hitler had from his house the burkhoff in salzburg okay so is that why they is that why they call it operation barbarossa well they're kind of thinking sort of groovy names are cool exciting potentially war-winning um operations and you know barbarossa is a bit of a kind of folk hero and you know the Germans are constantly sort of harking back with Nazis rather sort of harking
嗯，不，但我勇敢的老爸会回答的。他对这些了如指掌。所以弗雷德里克·巴巴罗萨是一位12世纪的皇帝，他在参加第三次十字军东征时溺水身亡。我猜他把名字留给希特勒对俄罗斯的入侵——对俄罗斯的入侵——的原因是，他有点像德国的亚瑟王，据说他——呃——在图林根山脉的一个山洞里，恩特斯堡。不，他也据说在恩特斯堡，那是希特勒从他在萨尔茨堡的住所贝格霍夫（Berchof）看到的风景。好吧，所以这就是他们——这就是他们把这叫做“巴巴罗萨行动”的原因吗？嗯，他们当时大概在想，一些时髦的名字很酷、很兴奋、可能带来战争的胜利——行动，你知道的，巴巴罗萨有点像某种民间英雄，你知道的，德国人不断地——纳粹其实有点像在——
back to this sort of weird sort of mythological period about which they don't know very much and they sort of mix it all up into this sort of you know world ice theory mixed with Arthurian myths mixed with Barbarossa and it all sort of goes into a kind of a sort of melting you know, world ice theory mixed with Arthurian myths, mixed with Barbarossa. And it all sort of goes into a kind of, a sort of melting pot of nonsense. And is that melting pot of nonsense part of what persuades Hitler to launch his invasion? No, no, it's not.
回顾这种奇怪的、关于他们其实并不十分了解的神话时期，他们把这一切揉合成某种——你知道的——世界冰理论，混杂着亚瑟王神话，又混杂着巴巴罗萨，这一切最终都变成了一种——某种熔炉——你知道的，世界冰理论混杂着亚瑟王神话，混杂着巴巴罗萨。这一切最终都变成了一种、某种胡说八道的熔炉。而这种胡说八道熔炉是说服希特勒发动入侵的部分原因吗？不，不，不是的。
Well, the melting pot of nonsense in so much that they absolutely believe in their own superiority and believe that the Soviets are, and East Europeans are Slavs and Untermenschen, all that stuff is absolutely the case. And you see this right from the very top, right down to the very bottom of people recording in their diaries, whether they be senior generals or whether they be, you know, ordinary lancers, they sort of go, you know, I looked at this person and I just realised sort of how primitive they were and how appalling they were and all that kind of stuff. Okay.
嗯，这个胡说八道熔炉的意义在于，他们绝对相信自己的优越性，相信苏联人、东欧人是斯拉夫人和劣等人（Untermenschen），所有这些说法绝对都是事实。你可以从最高层一直看到最底层在日记中记录的人，无论是高级将领还是普通的枪骑兵，他们都会说，你知道的，我看这个人时，我才意识到这个人是多么原始，多么糟糕，诸如此类的事情。好吧。
So James, let's do a bit of context and then we'll do a bit of chronology. So we are in, I mean, the operation begins on Sunday, the 22nd of June, 1941. It's one of these extraordinary set pieces in the history, you know, this colossal invasion force crossing the frontiers into the Soviet Union. It's a turning point in the Second World War. It's one of the great moments in the Second World War. So at one of the great moments in the Second World War. So at that point, to external observers, Hitler has had his tremendous successes in the West, the low countries, France, Scandinavia, and so on.
所以詹姆斯，我们来做一点背景介绍，然后我们再讲一点年表。所以我们现在正处于——我的意思是，这次行动开始于1941年6月22日，星期日。这是历史上一场非凡的重头戏，你知道的，这支庞大的侵略军越过边国边界进入苏联。这是第二次世界大战的一个转折点。这是第二次世界大战中的伟大时刻之一。因此，在第二次世界大战的伟大时刻之一时。所以在那时，在外部观察家看来，希特勒在西方取得了巨大的成功，低地国家、法国、斯堪的纳维亚等等。
Britain has been resisting alone. We talked about that with you before when we were talking about the summer of 1940. Alone along with the Empire and Dominions. Yeah, alone. Okay, alone in Europe, shall we say. And 85% of the world's merchant shipping. Oh, God, but yes.
英国一直在孤军奋战。我们以前在谈论1940年夏天时跟你讨论过这一点。与帝国和自治领并肩作战的孤军。是的，孤军奋战。好吧，可以说是欧洲的孤军奋战。以及占世界85%的商船。哦，天哪，但是是的。
Tom, we've got to stop having these woke guests on the show. So, okay. So Britain, as you just rightly said, James, was standing alone. And at what point – so Hitler has, as many listeners will know, the prelude to the second world war was that um the nazis and the soviet union signed the molotov-ribbentrop pact so the non-aggression pact and they basically divided you know poland between them the soviet union had taken the baltic states and now we had a question from jorge layton uh was there any chance of Hitler honoring the Ribbentrop-Molotov Pact? So 1940 going into 1941, is Hitler already planning the attack on the Soviet Union? Has he been planning it all along? Or to be a clash of arms at some point between Nazi Germany and the USSR.
汤姆，我们得停止在节目中邀请这些“觉醒派”嘉宾了。所以，好吧。英国，正如你刚才正确指出的那样，詹姆斯，当时正在孤军奋战。在哪个时间点——所以希特勒拥有，正如许多听众所知，第二次世界大战的序幕是——呃——纳粹德国和苏联签署了《莫洛托夫-里宾特洛普条约》，也就是互不侵犯条约，他们基本上瓜分了——你知道的——波兰，苏联夺取了波罗的海诸国，现在我们有一个来自豪尔赫·莱顿（Jorge Leyton）的问题：希特勒有任何履行《里宾特洛普-莫洛托夫条约》的可能吗？所以从1940年进入1941年，希特勒当时已经在计划对苏联的进攻了吗？他一直都在计划吗？还是说纳粹德国与苏联之间在某个时刻必将爆发武装冲突。
When that happens and what form it takes is obviously completely up for grabs at that point. Hitler is originally sort of thinking he doesn't think of the Second World War as the Second World War. He thinks it is a series of of limited operations. So the first limiting operation is against Poland. And, you know, that's sort of done and dusted in a matter of weeks, pretty much on schedule. Then the second one is obviously going into Scandinavia. That's another limited operation which sees Denmark and Norway fall under the Nazi yoke. Then the third one, of course, is the invasion of the West, Casey Yellow, which is the low countries in France.
当这种情况发生时，它以什么形式出现，在当时显然是完全未定的。希特勒最初的想法是——他不认为第二次世界大战是第二次世界大战。他认为这是一系列有限的行动。因此，第一次有限的行动是针对波兰的。而且，你知道的，这在几周内就搞定了，几乎完全按计划进行。然后第二次行动显然是进入斯堪的纳维亚。那是另一次有限的行动，导致丹麦和挪威落入纳粹的枷锁之下。然后第三次行动，当然是对西方的入侵，“黄色方案”（Casey Yellow），也就是低地国家和法国。
And France is a big one, you know, by today's standards. France is a superpower in 1940 and crushed in six weeks so these are all limited operations as far as he's concerned you know with britain britain's lost its army which is the sort of biggest humiliation of all um because he's a landlubber and a continentalist so that's how he you know that's what he views is the most important thing um so he's expecting britain to sue for peace um and the war is won and then at some point a few years down the line when he sort of you of built up some more stocks and built up some more strength
法国可是一个大国，你知道的，按今天的标准来看。法国在1940年是一个超级大国，却在六周内被粉碎。所以在他看来，这些都是有限的行动，你知道的，随着英国——英国失去了它的军队，这是所有屈辱中最大的一次——呃——因为他是一个旱鸭子和欧洲大陆本土主义者，所以这就是他——你知道的——他认为最重要的事情是什么——所以他期望英国求和——然后战争就赢了——然后在几年后的某个时候，当他——你知道的——积累了更多的库存，积聚了更多的力量，
and kind of got an even bigger army, then he'll invade the Soviet Union, perhaps 1943, perhaps 1944, something like that. But it's the Battle of Britain that forces his hand because he doesn't win. Britain is still in the fight. America's hovering in the background, sort of fighting a proxy war,
并建立起一支更庞大的军队时，他才会入侵苏联，也许是在1943年，也许是在1944年，诸如此类。但正是“不列颠之战”迫使他动手，因为他没有赢。英国仍在战斗。美国在背景中盘旋，进行着某种代理人战争，
delivering arms to Britain, et cetera, et cetera. And so he realizes that actually he needs to regain strength and particularly resources of food, especially agriculturally. Because the Royal Navy are throttling the conflict. Yes, because from the 1st of September 1939, there is an economic blockade. And if you look at your geography and look at the map, you see that Germany's got a sort of very complicated little bit of sort of Baltic coast at the top, which is sort of get out into the world,
向英国运送武器，等等，等等。因此他意识到，实际上他需要恢复实力，尤其是食物资源，特别是农业方面的食物。因为皇家海军正在扼杀这场冲突。是的，因为从1939年9月1日起，就存在着经济封锁。如果你看一下地理，看看地图，你就会发现德国在顶部有一个非常复杂的、小小的波罗的海海岸线，那是某种通往世界的地方，
you know, to get out into the North Sea, you've got to sort of get through lots of narrow channels and through islands and things. Then there's a little strip of the North Sea coast, and that's it. And even with France subdued, you know, the blockade is still extant. And the Royal Navy is the world's largest at the time.
你知道的，要想进入北海，你必须穿过许多狭窄的航道、岛屿之类的地方。然后是北海海岸的一小条狭长地带，仅此而已。即使在法国被制服之后，你知道的，封锁依然存在。而且皇家海军是当时世界上最大的海军。
So it's pretty effective at blockading. And they don't have enough fuel. They don't have enough food. And going into all those occupied territories in 1940 and early part of 1941, they've been a bit like sort of children in a sweet shop. And they've just, you know, the cupboard is bare very, very quick order.
所以它的封锁相当有效。他们没有足够的燃料。他们没有足够的食物。在1940年和1941年初进入所有这些被占领的领土时，他们有点像糖果店里的孩子们。他们刚刚，你知道的，储藏室在非常非常短的时间内就空空如也了。
And I'll give you an example of this. So in January 1940, France is the most automotive country in Europe. And there are eight people in France for every motorized vehicle, whereas that figure is 47 in Germany and 106 in Italy. And by the 31st of December 1940, France has 8% left of the vehicles that it had on the 1st of January. Goodness. Wow.
我给你们举个例子。所以在1940年1月，法国是欧洲汽车化程度最高的国家。法国每8个人拥有一辆机动车辆，而德国这一数字是47人，意大利是106人。到1940年12月31日，法国剩下的车辆仅为1月1日时的8%。天哪。哇。
Because the Germans have just nicked it all. They've just nicked it all. And they've nicked everything and they've taken all the coal and they've taken that. So suddenly all those factories don't work anymore. Right. So those factories don't work either. And that's the key thing.
因为德国人把它们全抢光了。他们把它们全抢光了。他们抢走了一切，他们拿走了所有的煤炭，他们拿走了那些。所以突然之间，所有那些工厂都无法运转了。对。所以那些工厂也无法运转了。这才是关键所在。
Well, no, because, you know, but France is suffering from the economic blockade, as is Denmark, as is Norway, as is everyone within Nazi Germany's, you know, Greater Reich, because the blockade exists for all of them. I mean, you know, it's stopping all of them. So France is suffering from that. But it's also suffering from the fact that their industrial complexes don't work very efficiently anymore, because all the things that make an industrial complex work, coal, workforce, food for the workforce, fuel, oil, cars to get people to the workforce to move things out of the workforce, workforce, food for the workforce, fuel, oil, cars to get people to the workforce,
嗯，不，因为，你知道的，但是法国正遭受着经济封锁的痛苦，丹麦也是，挪威也是，纳粹德国——你知道的——大德意志帝国内的每一个人都在遭受痛苦，因为封锁对他们所有人来说都是存在的。我的意思是，你知道的，它阻止了他们所有人。所以法国正在为此痛苦。但它也因为其工业复合体不再能高效运转而痛苦，因为使工业复合体运转的所有东西——煤炭、劳动力、劳动力的食物、燃料、石油、让劳动力上班、把东西运出工作场所的汽车，劳动力、劳动力的食物、燃料、石油、让劳动力上班的汽车，
to move things out of the workforce, trains, locomotives, all the rest of it. All that has been stolen by the Germans, so it doesn't function anymore. So at what point, James, do you think, well, do we know from the sort of archival sources, do we know the point at which Hitler said to his generals, OK, we're going to go into the Soviet Union now? Yes. So the first decision is mooted in July 1940, when Britain doesn't come to the peace zone. Yeah, yeah. He's not convinced about it.
把东西运出工作场所的汽车、火车、机车以及其他所有东西。所有这些都被德国人偷走了，所以它不再能运转了。那么詹姆斯，你认为在哪个时刻——嗯，我们从某种档案资料中知道吗——我们是否知道希特勒对他的将军们说“好吧，我们现在要进入苏联了”的那个时刻？是的。因此，第一个决定是在1940年7月提出的，当时英国没有前来谈和。是的，是的。他对此并不确信。
He's not absolutely, yeah, we're definitely going to go. But it sort of builds, and you can see him becoming, as it's absolutely clear that the Luftwaffe is not going to subdue the RAF, and it's going to be completely impossible to do a cross-channel invasion. I mean, even Hitler, who's a sort of military nincompoop, even he can see that the conditions have not been met by September 1940. And therefore, you know, what do you do? You've got to have a problem because Britain's still in the,
他不是绝对的，是的，我们一定要去。但它一直在积蓄，你可以看到他变得——当绝对清楚的是，德国空军（Luftwaffe）无法压制英国皇家空军（RAF），且跨海峡入侵将变得完全不可能时。我的意思是，甚至连希特勒这个军事笨蛋，连他也能看出到1940年9月时条件尚未成熟。因此，你知道的，你该怎么办？你必须面对一个问题，因为英国仍然在局中，
it's still got skin in the game. So what are you going to do? Well, okay, here's a plan. We know that the Slavs are are under mention we know that they were completely useless in the finished finished war um of late 1939 through to the beginning of 1940 um we know they've had the purges and have killed sort of you know executed four of their six marshals 23,000 officers etc etc so how hard can it be especially since we've just won in France which is a kind of superpower and had you know is a modern functioning northern European state for the most part so you know how hard can
它仍然深陷其中。所以你打算怎么做？好吧，好吧，这里有个计划。我们知道斯拉夫人是劣等人，我们知道他们在1940年底到1940年初的苏芬战争中完全无能——呃——我们知道他们经历过大清洗，杀害了——你知道的——处决了他们六个元帅中的四个，23,000名军官，等等，等等。所以这能有多难呢？尤其是既然我们刚刚在法国获胜，法国算是一个超级大国，而且大部分是一个现代运作的北欧国家。所以你知道，这能有多难呢？
it be and that's that's where the thinking starts to starts to come in and suddenly it's the only solution in fact actually by the spring of 1941 there is only there are only two viable options left to Hitler and the Nazi regime one is to go into the USSR and hope it works or sue for peace and obviously he's not going to do the latter. You said that he'd been, essentially the moment he came to power, it was inevitable that Nazi Germany would go to war with the Soviet Union. Or the Soviet Union would go to war with Nazi Germany. But from the Nazi point of view, why is that?
这就是思考开始产生的时候，突然之间，这成了唯一的解决方案。事实上，到了1941年春天，希特勒和纳粹政权面前实际上只剩下两个可行的选项：一个是进入苏联并希望它能起作用，另一个是求和。显然，他是不会选择后者的。你说过他一直——基本上从他上台的那一刻起，纳粹德国与苏联开战就是不可避免的。或者说苏联与纳粹德国开战。但从纳粹的角度来看，这是为什么呢？
Is that because the Slavs are living in Lebensraum that the Germans should claim? Or is it because they're communist? Is it the racial or is it the ideological aspects of the Soviet Union that are most offensive to Hitler? It's both. It's the idea that the world is threatened from a takeover of communism orchestrated by global Jewry. Yeah, they're surely interwoven, Tom.
是因为斯拉夫人生活在德国人应该声称拥有的生存空间（Lebensraum）里吗？还是因为他们是共产主义者？对希特勒来说，最具有冒犯性的是苏联的种族方面还是意识形态方面？两者皆有。这就是世界受到由全球犹太人精心策划的共产主义接管威胁的观点。是的，它们肯定是交织在一起的，汤姆。
Completely. So the Soviet Union are communists because they are, unto mention. Yes, and communisms are really, really hated by the Germans because, for those Germans
完全交织在一起。因此，苏联人是共产主义者，因为他们是劣等人。是的，而且德国人对共产主义真的、真的很痛恨——对于那些不是共产主义者的德国人来说，我应该这么说——因为共产主义者被视为第一次世界大战结束的主要原因之一，因为正是德国海军中的一场共产主义哗变，某种程度上拉开了第一次世界大战结束的整场摊牌的序幕，因为正是德国海军中的一场共产主义哗变，某种程度上拉开了整个——你知道的——走向终局的摊牌的序幕。如果你是个纳粹分子，你最大的敌人就是共产主义者。
who aren't communists, I should say, because communists are seen as one of the main causes of the end of the First World War because it was a communist mutiny in the German Navy that sort of kick-started the whole showdown to the end of the First World War, because it was a communist mutiny in the German Navy that sort of kickstarted the whole sort of, you know, showdown to the end. And if you're a Nazi, your worst enemy is a communist.
这就是为什么那么多人支持纳粹，事实上，比如法国的那么多人选择站在纳粹德国一边，而不是站在盟军、自由法国以及其他所有人一边，原因之一就是对共产主义向西蔓延的恐惧。我的意思是，这是一种现实而紧迫的危险，就像对英国人等人来说，纳粹主义向西蔓延的危险一样。所以，詹姆斯，如果那是——我的意思是，希特勒从未掩饰过他的反共立场或他对斯拉夫人的厌恶等等。
And one of the reasons so many people back the Nazis, and indeed so many people in France, for example, side with Nazi Germany rather than, you know, the Allies and the Free French and all the rest of it, is because of that fear of the westward spread of communism. I mean, that is as clear and present a danger as is the westward spread of Nazism to those in Britain, for example. So, James, if that's... I mean, Hitler has never hidden his anti-communism or his loathing for Slavs and so on.
鉴于这一切，鉴于他早在1940年夏天就在跟将军们交谈，或者在私下里谈论进攻苏联，为什么苏联——苏联领导层——是如此庞大，苏联的人力资源绝对是极其巨大的——而且也是因为，在很大程度上，实际上苏联已经在资源方面——基本资源方面——源源不断地供给纳粹德国了。当然，你一旦入侵，这些供应就会被切断，直到你彻底获胜并能够夺取这些资源——这些资源包括石油和天然气。是的，还有食物、铝土矿和钨。所以来自乌克兰的食物、粮仓以及所有这些东西？是的，所有这些东西。
And given all that, and given that he is talking to his generals or he's talking in private about attacking the Soviet Union as early as the summer of 1940, why is it that the Soviet Union, the Soviet leadership union is so vast and the manpower reserves of the soviet union are just absolutely enormous um and also because to a certain to a very large extent actually the soviet union is already feeding nazi germany in terms of resources essential resources and of course the moment you invade these get cut off until you've completely won and you can take those resources are include oil and gas Yes, and food and bauxite and tungsten. So food from Ukraine, the breadbasket and all that kind of stuff? Yeah, all that sort of stuff.
但关键在于他们想为自己占有这些。他们不想与任何斯拉夫人和劣等人分享。这就是他们的想法。那么，斯大林认为，反正我们都在给希特勒所有这些东西，入侵我们根本不符合他的利益。斯大林是这么想的吗？嗯，部分原因是这不符合他的利益，入侵我们不符合他的利益。斯大林是这么想的吗？嗯，部分是这个原因，但部分也是因为斯大林太天真了。我的意思是，斯大林经历了20世纪30年代末的大清洗，
But the point is they want it for themselves. They don't want to share it with any Slavs and intermentals. So that's their thinking. So what, Stalin thinks we're giving Hitler all this stuff anyway, it's just simply not in his interest to invade us. Is that what Stalin thinks? Well, it's partly that not in his interest to invade us. Is that what Stalin thinks? Well, it's partly that, but it's also partly Stalin being naive. I mean, Stalin's gone through these purges of the late 1930s,
武装部队——红军——陷入混乱，但他们正在做准备，做了大量的工作并进行建设，你知道的，到1941年夏天，他们拥有的火炮数量是德国的两倍。他们拥有的飞机数量大约是——到1941年夏天，他们拥有的火炮数量是德国的两倍。他们拥有的飞机数量大约是六倍。现在，其中许多飞机已经过时，不再适合原定用途，但它们仍然是飞机。坦克也是如此，你知道，新型坦克正在源源不断地运来。所以他们也在加紧备战。毫无疑问，他们正在准备与纳粹德国进行摊牌，并且在考虑率先发动进攻。
and the armed forces, the Red Army, is in disarray, but they are preparing and doing an awful lot of work and building, you know, they've got double the number of artillery pieces that Germany has by the summer of 1941. They've got something like got double the number of artillery pieces that Germany has by the summer of 1941. They've got something like six times the number of aircraft. Now, a lot of those are obsolescent and no longer kind of fit for purpose, but it's still aircraft. Ditto with tanks, you know, the new tanks are coming in. So they are gearing up as well. And there's no question about it that they are preparing for a showdown with Nazi Germany and that they're thinking about invading first.
我的意思是，你知道的，这将会发生——因为斯大林看到——就像纳粹害怕共产主义向西蔓延一样，共产主义者也害怕纳粹主义向东蔓延。所以也是如此，他们可能会这么做。只是尽管有大量证据表明这将会发生，斯大林却拒绝接受。这就是那种诡异的、无法解释的事情之一，
I mean, you know, it is going to happen because Stalin sees, you know, in the same way that the Nazis fear the Western threat of spread of communism, the communists fear the Eastern spread of Nazism. So as well, they might as well. They might. It's just that despite huge amounts of evidence that this is going to happen, Stalin refuses to accept it. And it's one of those weird, inexplicable things
他有一会儿完全失去了理智。非常迅速地，有一会儿，他绝对成了车灯前的兔子。然后非常非常迅速地，他恢复了镇定。所以这一切都在发生，每个人都在说，你知道，开始吧——“你知道，同志，我——你知道，我认为有很多迹象表明德国人正在搞什么鬼。”“胡说，胡说。”所以我们来谈谈这个吧，我们正走向1941年，但希特勒最初的计划并不是在他实际入侵的那个时间点入侵——所以入侵被推迟了，不是吗？所以他被迫、被催促着更早地动手——
where he just completely loses the plot for a bit. And very quickly, for a moment, he's absolutely that rabbit in the headlights. And very, very quickly, he gets a grip. So there's all that, everyone's sort of going you know start um you know comrade i'm you know i think there's quite a few signs that the germans are kind of up to something no nonsense nonsense so let's talk about that we're getting to 1941 but hitler's initial plan is not to invade when he does invade so the invasion is put off isn't it so he's forced into he's hustled into it doing it much early
伞兵黑手党，你觉得如果进攻按原计划在5月份发起，结果会有所不同吗？这是因为墨索里尼卷入了巴尔干和希腊的冲突。是的，不，这不会产生任何实质性的差别的，因为根本的问题……给我们讲讲为什么希特勒必须首先推迟它，然后告诉我们为什么这实际上没有任何区别。
parachute mafia do you think the outcome would have been different if the offensive was launched in May as originally planned? And that's because Mussolini has got embroiled in the Balkans and Greece. Yeah, no, it wouldn't have made any difference whatsoever because the fundamental problems... Just tell us about why Hitler has to delay it first and then tell us why it doesn't actually make any difference.
所以这一切的关键在于……因此，意大利和德国之间签署的“钢铁条约”其实只是一场权宜之盟。其构想是，墨索里尼不必担心他的北部侧翼，他可以集中精力建立一个新的罗马帝国，
So the whole point of that... So the Pact of Steel, which is signed between Italy and Germany, is really an alliance of convenience. So the idea is that Mussolini doesn't have to worry about his northern flank and he can just concentrate on creating a new Roman empire,
你知道的，“我们的海”（Mare Nostrum）以及所有这些，地中海，并一直延伸到东非、北非等等，以及整个爱琴海。这就是他的雄心，要拥有一个帝国，这个帝国在范围上——在很多方面可以说是古罗马式的，除了欧洲那部分。希特勒一点也不想为他的南部侧翼操心。
you know, the Mari Nostrum and all the rest of it, the Mediterranean, and stretching all the way down into East Africa and North Africa and so on and the whole of the Aegean. That's his ambition, to have an empire which is sort of,
你知道的，由于德国在欧洲的中心位置，它相当脆弱，他希望能够随时专注于进攻西方和进攻东方，而不必担心他的南部侧翼。但不幸的是，墨索里尼也是个军事笨蛋，装备甚至更差，他
you know, sort of old Roman in kind of sort of scope in many ways, apart from the Europe bit. And Hitler doesn't want to have to worry about his southern flank at all. You know, because of Germany's central position in Europe, it's quite vulnerable, and he wants to be able to just sort of concentrate on attacking the West and attacking the East whenever he wants to without having to worry about his southern flank. But unfortunately, Mussolini is also a military nincompoop and even worse equipped and he goes
首先进入希腊，把事情搞得一团糟，希腊人进行反击；然后他入侵了英国保护国埃及，英国人进行了反击，也把事情搞得一团糟。所以希特勒不得不去救援他，否则就会面临失去南部侧翼、使南部侧翼变得脆弱的风险。他的南部侧翼特别宝贵，因为罗马尼亚是德国唯一的石油来源，这对他的战争机器至关重要。因此他根本冒不起这个险。所以他必须去稳住阵脚并帮助他的盟友意大利。这涉及进入巴尔干，涉及向北非派遣军队，也涉及入侵希腊。我认为你可以非常有力地辩称，这并不涉及
into Greece first of all and makes a complete hash of it and the Greeks fight back and then he goes invades Egypt which is a British protectorate and the British fight back and makes a complete hash of that as well so Hitler has to come to his rescue or risk lose his southern flank and make his southern flank vulnerable and his southern flank vulnerable. And his southern flank is particularly precious because Romania is the only source of German oil, of which is of vital importance to his war machine. And so he just cannot risk it. So he has to go and shore things up and help out his ally, Italy. And that involves going into the Balkans, it involves sending troops to North Africa and it also involves invading Greece. I think you can argue very strongly that it doesn't involve
进入克里特岛，但无论如何，他们确实进去了，他们失去了50%训练有素最好的步兵部队——伞兵（Fallschirmjäger），他们还损失了另外250架运输机，这些运输机在“巴巴罗萨行动”中绝对会非常有用，但它们并不是他们战败的原因。但这延迟了开始的时间。这让开始时间推迟了一个月，是的。那为什么这并不重要呢？因为许许多多的人说，是的，那是非常重大的。嗯，这确实是整个播客的核心，因为我认为他们从来没有什么获胜的几率，因为他们必须实现的目标规模太庞大了，而且对他们来说非常悲惨的是——他们的资源与他们赋予自己的任务相比严重不足。
going into Crete but be that as it may they do, they lose 50% of their most well-trained infantry troops, the paratroopers, the Fallschirmjäger and they also lose a further 250 transport aircraft which certainly would have been incredibly useful in Operation Barbarossa but they're not the reason why they lose. But it delays the start. It delays the start by a month, yeah. So why is that not significant? Because lots and lots of people say, yes, that was hugely significant. Well, this is really the crux of the entire podcast, because I don't think they ever had much chance of winning because the scale of what they had to achieve was so enormous and they were tragically um for them um massively under-resourced for the tasks that they'd given
这完全归咎于误判、狂妄自大、完全缺乏自我意识——以及低估了敌人、低估了挑战，而且有许许多多警告，而他们却把这些全部忽视了。嗯，首先，我的意思是，他们毕竟还是拥有庞大的兵力，不是吗？我正读到这里。他们拥有数千辆坦克、4000架飞机。有多少个师？153个师。
themselves and that was down to just a misappreciation hubris um total lack of of self-awareness um and of underestimating the enemy and underestimating the challenges and there were lots and lots of warnings, and they just ignored them all. Well, first of all, I mean, they do have nevertheless colossal numbers, don't they? I'm just reading here. They have thousands of tanks, 4,000 aircraft. How many divisions? 153 divisions.
我的意思是，那是……无论如何，他们建立起了这一切。这种延迟大概也是为什么会有这么多谣言的原因——我的意思是，总有那些著名的故事，关于有人溜过边境、游过河流或者诸如此类的事情，然后跑到红军面前说：“我有情报，”
I mean, that's... Anyway, they build all that up. And the delay presumably gives is one reason why there are so many rumors i mean there's always these famous stories about sort of people slipping across frontiers and swimming rivers or whatever and pitching up and saying to the to the red army i have information yeah you know and then being shot as their as their kind of reward or being thrown into prison or something why is it so at this at this point, so we're sort of May, June. Do – as this huge military buildup, do some people in the Soviet kind of hierarchy,
你知道的，然后作为回报被枪决，或者被投入监狱什么的。为什么在这个时候——所以我们大约在5月、6月——随着这支庞大的军事力量集结，苏联高层中的一些人，
do they know it's happening but Stalin's refusing to listen? Or are they all deluding themselves that these are just Nazi exercises? Well, if you remember the last few months before the Russian attack on Ukraine, there were troop build-ups, troop build-ups all along, weren't there? And everyone's going, no, it's not going to happen. He's not really going to do it. Or he might do it, but it might just be kind of...
他们知道这件事正在发生，但斯大林拒绝听取意见吗？还是说他们都在自欺欺人，认为这些只是纳粹的演习？嗯，如果你还记得俄罗斯进攻乌克兰前的几个月，到处都有军队集结，到处都是军队集结，不是吗？每个人都说，不，这不会发生。他不会真的这么做。或者他可能会这么做，但这可能只是一种……
It's just a tactic. Yeah, just a political game. So it's the same sort of thing. The key point about it is, yes, they're attacking with 3.6 million men. It is the largest clash of arms in terms of scale that the world has ever seen. But it is simply not enough because 3.6 million sounds a huge number. Of course, it is a vast number. But that needs contextualising because 90% of the hard yards has to be done by a quarter to a third of the troops involved. So the absolute key,
这只是一种战术。是的，只是一场政治游戏。所以这是同一种事情。其中的关键点在于，是的，他们是以360万大军发起进攻的。就规模而言，这是世界上见过的最大规模的武装冲突。但这根本不够，因为360万听起来是一个巨大的数字。当然，这是一个庞大的数字。但这需要置于语境中来看，因为90%的硬仗必须由所涉及军队的四分之一到三分之一来完成。所以绝对的关键，
because Germany is so under-mechanised, the lion's share of the work, the absolute spearhead, is carried out by these four panzer groups. And the panzer groups are effectively groups of mechanised armies. They're groups of all-arms units, of motorised infantry, motorised artillery, and of course tanks, bmw motorbikes with sidecars and all the rest of it and half tracks and armor cars and you know when you when you think when you think blitzkrieg nazis on the march that's what you're thinking about but that accounts for only 39 divisions and of those only 17 are panzer divisions and the panzer divisions are the creme de la creme you know these are the all arms and one of those 39 divisions is the first cavalry division which
因为德国的机械化程度如此之低，最重的工作、绝对的锋芒是由这四个装甲集群（panzer groups）执行的。而装甲集群实际上就是机械化集团军群。它们是由全兵种部队组成的集团军群，包括摩托化步兵、摩托化炮兵，当然还有坦克、带有边三轮的宝马摩托车以及其他所有车辆、半履带车和装甲车，你知道的——当你想到闪击战、纳粹在行进时，你脑子里想的就是这个。但这只占了39个师，其中只有17个是装甲师，而装甲师是精英中的精英，你知道的，这些是全兵种部队。这39个师中有一个是第一骑兵师，也就是
is horses yeah it's horses the germans you know the modern germans the the conquerors of europe they are going into the biggest clash of arms with a horsed mounted cavalry division in their spearhead so once you sort of break that down, you know, 39 divisions, each division is 15,000 men, of which only about, you know, 9 to 10,000 are actually fighting troops. So that's only about, you know, 400,000 men are doing 90% of the work. And 400,000 is a lot less than 3.6 million. So there is a kind of obvious parallel with what's been happening in in ukraine that actually the huge size of the russian army it's actually people say it's not big enough and and you could say the same about the germans well because you need guys to you need guys to drive
马匹，是的，全都是马。德国人——你知道的，现代德国人，欧洲的征服者——他们在他们进攻的锋芒中，带着一个骑马的骑兵师去参加有史以来最大规模的武装冲突。所以一旦你把这些分解开来，你知道，39个师，每个师15,000人，其中只有大约——你知道的，9,000到10,000人是实际的战斗部队。所以只有大约——你知道的，40万人在做90%的工作。而40万人远比360万人要少。所以这与乌克兰正在发生的事情有一个显而易见的相似之处：实际上俄罗斯军队的庞大体量——人们说它还不够大，你对德国人也可以这么说。嗯，因为你需要人来驾驶
the wholesome wagons and supply chains and all the rest of it so the question is are there people in the in the german army who are pointing this out who are worrying about this who are drawing up yeah and this is what's really interesting. So in the planning of Barbarossa, so one of the people who's been told to do sort of war game it, sort of sand table it, so do a sort of you know, a theoretical planning.
运粮马车、供应链以及其他所有东西。所以问题是，德国军队里有没有人指出这一点？有没有人为之担忧？有没有人拟定——是的，这才是真正有趣的地方。因此，在“巴巴罗萨行动”的规划中，被告知要进行某种兵棋推演、沙盘推演的人之一——也就是进行某种理论规划。
Not an actual war game, but kind of, you know, on paper, what have we got? Where does this work? How are you going to set it? How's it going to go? And appreciation. Is General Friedrich Paulus, who later... Oh, the irony. The irony. So, commander in Stalingrad. Yeah, but in 1940, he is on the OKW,
不是实际的兵棋推演，而是某种，你知道的，在纸面上：我们有什么？这在哪里行得通？你打算怎么部署？它将如何进展？以及进行评估。这个人就是弗里德里希·保卢斯将军（General Friedrich Paulus），他后来……哦，这真是讽刺。这真是讽刺。斯大林格勒战役中的指挥官。是的，但在1940年，他在陆军最高统帅部（OKW）任职，
which is the Oberkommando der Wehrmacht, which is the German combined staff, combined forces general staff, and basically Hitler's mouthpiece. And he does this study, and he sort of goes oh i'm not quite sure this is going to work actually um you know it's just not stacking up you know the distance to do great the logistic chains of this huge huge huge logistic problems and everyone goes let's not worry about it you know we've got the triumph of the will triumph
即德国武装部队最高统帅部（Oberkommando der Wehrmacht），也就是德国联合参谋部、联合部队总参谋部，基本上是希特勒的代言人。他做了这项研究，然后他说：“哦，我不太确定这是否行得通——你知道的，这根本行不通，你知道，要去那么远，后勤链有巨大、巨大、巨大的后勤问题。”每个人都说：“别担心，你知道，我们有《意志的胜利》，《意志的胜利》，一切都会好起来的，你知道的，他们自己就是劣等人，会没事的，我们把它忘了吧。”每个人都说：“好吧，好吧。”然后有一种——好吧，那么对这件事情的经济评估是什么呢？你知道的，我们怎么运转？你知道的，我们的石油够不够？我们的橡胶够不够？我们是否有——我们是否有足够的食物，你知道的，补给线？我们是否有足够的卡车来完成它？你知道的，来维持这种努力？因为德国战争方式的全部意义就在于“重点”（Schwerpunkt），你知道的，在主要点上狠狠地打击他们，来一场巨大的歼灭战（Kesselschlacht）和包围战，非常迅速地消灭你的敌人。
of the will it'll be fine you know we're there to mention their selves it'll be fine let's just forget about it and everyone sort of goes okay fine then then there is a kind of sort of okay so what's the economic appreciation of this you know how can we function you know have we got enough oil have we got enough rubber have we got have we got enough food you know the supply lines we've got enough trucks to kind of do it you know to maintain the effort because the whole point about the german way of war is is the schwerpunkt to kind of you know hit them hard at the main point do a huge great kettleettleschlacht and envelopment war, annihilate your enemy very quickly.
这一切都将是“砰、砰、砰、砰、砰”，你知道的，三周、六周、五天，诸如此类。而“巴巴罗萨行动”的全部意义在于，这应该是一场最多三个月的歼灭战。你知道的，如果在三个月内没有完成，那就游戏结束了，你知道，这没有起作用。所以乔治·托马斯将军（General George Thomas），如果你喜欢的话，也可以叫约科格·托马斯（Yorkorg Thomas），
It's all going to be wham, bam, bam, bam, bam, you know, three weeks, six weeks, five days, whatever. And the whole point about Barbarossa is that this is supposed to be a war of annihilation in three months max. You know, if it hasn't done it in three months, it's game over, you know, it hasn't worked. So General George Thomas, or Yorkorg Thomas, if you like,
他是OKW的负责人，即德国总参谋部的经济部、战时经济司（Wirtschafts- und Rüstungsamt），正如当时所称的那样。凯特尔（Keitel）向他提出了要求，凯特尔是参谋长。所以他是希特勒之下的绝对最高军事人物。1月22日，他被要求做一份经济评估。他在1941年2月8日向凯特尔提交了他的报告。这份报告相当具有谴责性。它说，好吧，你们将在两个月内耗尽燃料。我们将在六个月内耗尽橡胶。我们没有
he is the head of the OKW, the German General Staff's Economic Division, War Economic Vision, the Wirtschafts- und Rüstungsamt, as it was called. And he is asked by Keitel, who is the chief of staff. So he's the absolute top military guy under Hitler. And he's asked to do an economic appreciation on the 22nd of January. And he files his report with Keitel on the 8th of February 1941. And the report is quite damning. It says, well, you're going to run out of fuel in two months. We'll run out of rubber in six. We haven't got
足够的资源来维持它。我们不能依赖乌克兰人，因为德国人可能会实行焦土政策，等等等等。凯特尔只是说：“哦，不，不，不，这根本不行，滚开，重写去。”所以他说：“好的，呃——”他在五天后的2月13日回来了，说：“嗯，这将是 fantastisch（棒极了），是的，这将会是一件轻而易举的事。”每个人都说：“太好了，我们走吧。”我是说真的，这太疯狂了。这绝对是疯狂的。最重要的是——我的意思是，你知道，他们还有所有这些——因为希特勒的方式是进行这种“分而治之”，所以有很多这种平行的指挥结构。所以你有
enough to sustain it. We can't rely on the ukrainians because probably the germans will do a scorched earth policy blah blah blah and kaito just goes oh no no no no this won't do a go at all go away and rewrite it so he goes okay uh and he comes back on the 13th of february five days later going well it's gonna be fantastic yeah this is gonna be a piece of piss and everyone goes great let's go i mean seriously it's it's insane it's absolutely insane and on top of that i mean you know they're also all the because hitler's way is to have this sort of divide and rule so there's lots of these sort of parallel command structures so you have you have the the war economy office under under york thomas at the okw which is to do with military financing but that's also tied in with Goering's four-year plan.
OKW下属的约克·托马斯领导的战时经济办公室，这与军事融资有关。但这又与戈林（Goering）的四年计划挂钩。戈林现在拥有大部分——个人拥有大部分德国工业、重工业。然后你还有沃尔特·芬克（Walter Funk）的经济部。在这之下，你还有另外27个国家财政办公室，所有这些办公室都以某种方式完全互不衔接。你还有许许多多的小型工业。所以你没有任何类似国有英国铁路（British Rail）或类似的东西。因此，当他们入侵时，确实，他们的四个装甲集群拥有
And Goering now owns most of, personally owns, most of German industry, a heavy industry. Then you've got Walter Funk's Ministry of Economics as well. And then under that, you've also got 27 further national finance offices, all of which who are kind of sort of not remotely joined up in any way whatsoever. And you've got lots and lots of sort of small industries. So you haven't got any kind of nationalised sort of British Rail equivalent or anything like that. So consequently, when they invade, it's true, they've got, you know, zillions of vehicles for their four panzer groups and
无数的车辆和其他装备。但他们现在也有2,000种不同类型的车辆。现在，我相信你们俩都不是特别懂机械——我知道你完全不懂，老兄——但我知道，讨论历史卡车是汤姆你的心头好。好吧，这就是让我兴奋的地方。好吧，这里的重点是，当然，如果你是一个独立的卡车制造商，这就有点像——你知道的，在过去做独立马车制造商一样。
others. But they've also got 2000 different types of vehicle now i'm trusting that neither of you are particularly mechanical i know you're not at all bro but but tom i know the discussion of historical trucks is very dear to your heart well this is what i'm excited about well the point about this is is that of course if you're if you're an independent truck manufacturer it's a bit like you know in the old days being an independent horse and cart manufacturer. You know, you just do your own thing. And they all have certain principles. They've got a bit of suspension and they've got wheels and, you know,
你知道，你只管做你自己的事。它们都有某些原则。它们有一点悬挂装置，有车轮，你知道的，
they've got wooden bits and all the rest of it. But they're all different. And this is the problem with having 2,000 different vehicles, many of which are British, many of which are French. Because you don't have the bits to repair them. Because your distributor cap and your coil and your spark plugs and your
有木质部件等等。但它们全都不一样。这就是拥有2,000种不同车辆的问题所在，其中许多是英国的，许多是法国的。因为你没有零件来修理它们。因为你的分电器盖、线圈、火花塞和你的
gasket, you know, that's a word that you must have heard of. They're all different. Tom, you assured me before your brother came on this podcast that it would not, absolutely not degenerate into a discussion of World War II trucks, but it clearly has. No, I said that it would. It's a principle.
垫圈，你知道，这是一个你肯定听说过的词。它们各不相同。汤姆，在你弟弟上这个播客之前，你向我保证，这绝对、绝对不会演变成一场关于二战卡车的讨论，但很明显它已经演变成了。不，我说过会这样的。这是一个原则问题。
In the second half, we should talk about violence, about the sheer violence of the German attack. Yes, where it all goes wrong. And we should also talk about Ukraine specifically, because that was obviously the peg for doing it. But before we do that, one last question before the break, and it's about war aims. So the Nazis' dream scenario, James, you said, you know,
在下半场，我们应该谈谈暴力，谈谈德军进攻那种纯粹的暴力。是的，一切出错的地方。我们还应该具体谈谈乌克兰，因为这显然是做这件事的借口。但在我们这样做之前，中场休息前的最后一个问题，关于战争目标。所以纳粹的梦想剧本，詹姆斯，你刚才说，你知道，
they want to do it in two or three months. The Nazis dream scenario, where do they stop? And what has happened? And what does that involve? Does it involve the extermination of all the population? Does it involve massive slave camps, the implanting of settlements? I mean, what do they think is going to happen? They haven't really thought it through at all. So the idea is that they encircle the entire Red Army, who, when they invade, will come forward to meet them. They'll then encircle them in a massive giant encirclement or series of encirclements and destroy them within 500 kilometres of where they start,
他们想在两三个月内完成。纳粹的梦想剧本，他们会在哪里停下？发生了什么？这涉及什么？这涉及消灭所有人口吗？这涉及大规模的奴隶集中营、建立定居点吗？我的意思是，他们认为会发生什么？他们根本没有把这想清楚。所以他们的想法是包围整个红军，当他们入侵时，红军会向前迎击他们。然后他们将在一个巨大的包围圈或一系列包围圈中包围他们，并在他们出发地500公里范围内消灭他们，
which is sort of, you know, from the central point, is Brest in what is now Belarus, I think. Belarus, yeah, was Poland at the time. And that's the time. And that's the assumption. And almost every bit of that doesn't happen. And then what do they think will happen? Then they'll turn the whole of the Soviet Union into a Nazi empire?
也就是，你知道的，从中心点算起，大概是现在白俄罗斯的布列斯特，我想。白俄罗斯，是的，当时是波兰。这就是那个时间。这就是那个假设。而几乎其中的每一个部分都没有发生。然后他们以为会发生什么？然后他们要把整个苏联变成一个纳粹帝国？
They'll capture Moscow? Yeah, they'll capture Moscow. They haven't really thought about how far they'll go. So Moscow is their initial target, isn't it? I mean, and that's quite... No, their initial target is... No, their initial target is 500 kilometres to destroy the Red Army. But the German high command, their ultimate target is Moscow
他们会攻占莫斯科？是的，他们会攻占莫斯科。他们根本没考虑过他们会走多远。所以莫斯科是他们的最初目标，对吧？我的意思是，而且这相当……不，他们的最初目标是……不，他们的最初目标是500公里内消灭红军. 但德国最高指挥部，他们的最终目标是莫斯科
rather than Leningrad or Kiev. Yes, but they can walk into Moscow once they've destroyed the Red Army within 500 kilometres. So in other words, they think it'll be a little bit like the... I mean, neither Tom nor I are military specialists, so you should correct us if we're completely out of line. But they think it'll be a little bit like the conquest of France. So they won't have to have a siege of the capital.
而不是列宁格勒或基辅。是的，但一旦他们在500公里内消灭了红军，他们就可以大摇大摆地走进莫斯科。换句话说，他们认为这有点像……我的意思是，汤姆和我都不是军事专家，所以如果我们完全说错了，你应该纠正我们。但他们认为这有点像对法国的征服。所以他们不必对首都进行围困。
They'll just be able to waltz into the capital having already won the war. Exactly. Yeah, right. Exactly. That's exactly what they're thinking. And how it'll all pan out, they haven't really thought through at all. Right. And there are huge problems about going beyond the 500.
他们只要在已经赢得战争的情况下大摇大摆地走进首都就行了。完全正确。是的，没错。完全正确。这正是他们的想法。至于这一切将如何收场，他们根本没有想清楚。没错。而且超越500公里存在着巨大的问题。
The great thing about two Hollands is they just talk over one another and it just goes on forever. So that is the plan. Come back after the ad break and find out how it actually went. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews,
两个霍兰德的绝妙之处在于他们只会互相抢话，而且没完没了。所以这就是计划。广告回来后，来看看实际情况究竟如何。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐至上》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论，
splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
还有一点八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告的节目、独家番剧并抢先获得现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。
At this moment, a march is taking place that for its extent compares with the greatest the world has ever seen i have decided today to place the fate and future of the reich and our people in the hands of our soldiers may god aid us especially in this fight so that was very much not a friend of the rest of his history. Adolf Hitler making his debut on our podcast. Enough of him. So James Holland, brother of the lesser known Tom Holland. James, you're here to talk about Operation Barbarossa. And we've done all the war aims. We've done all the sort of planning and what you see as the shambolic planning.
此时此刻，一场规模堪称世界之最的游行正在进行。我今天决定将帝国和我人民的命运与未来交托给我们士兵的手中，愿上帝在这个特殊的时刻保佑我们的这场战斗。所以这绝对不是《历史至上》的朋友。阿道夫·希特勒在我们的播客中首次亮相。够了。所以詹姆斯·霍兰德，不太出名的汤姆·霍兰德的弟弟。詹姆斯，你来这里是为了谈论“巴巴罗萨行动”。我们已经讨论了所有的战争目标。我们已经讨论了所有的计划以及你所看到的混乱的计划。
So the day itself, I mean, the moment that it happens, it happens in the early hours of the morning as these things tend to, and it appears to be a complete triumph for the Germans. I mean, they carry on before them. The Soviet Union are completely taken by surprise. Disaster. They're entire, basically, am I right in thinking that the Soviet operational command or whatever is completely blown away in the opening hours opening hours of the war completely blown away completely blown away uh they have these series of encirclements and actually smolensk is captured on the 15th of july so you know what's that 15 plus you know eight um
所以在这一天本身，我的意思是，事情发生的那个时刻，它发生在清晨，就像这类事情往往发生的那样，这似乎对德国人来说是一个完全的胜利。我的意思是，他们在前面高歌猛进。苏联人完全被打了个措手不及。灾难。他们的整个，基本上，我这样认为对吗：苏联的作战指挥部或类似的东西在战争爆发的最初几个小时内被彻底摧毁了？战争爆发的最初几个小时内被彻底摧毁了？完全摧毁了？完全摧毁了？呃，他们经历了一系列包围圈，事实上斯摩棱斯克在7月15日被攻占，所以你知道，那是15日加上（我知道）8天……
in just over three weeks um which is incredible you know and smolensk is what 700 kilometers so it's it's beyond that great they've captured three quarters of a million men, so many that they don't know what to do with them. They capture so many because people are ready to surrender. It's a failure of the high command. It's not that they, no, not really. It's not that they are particularly ready to surrender. It's just that there is a failure of leadership at the very, very top for a whole host of reasons. It's too cumbersome. It's too top-heavy. It's too controlled. But within very quick order, Stalin and the senior commanders
在短短三个多星期内，呃，这真是令人难以置信，你知道，斯摩棱斯克大概是700公里，所以它已经超出了那个范围。太棒了，他们俘虏了75万士兵，人数之多以至于他们不知道该拿他们怎么办。他们俘虏了这么多人，是因为人们准备投降。这是最高指挥部的失误。并不是说他们，不，不完全是。并不是说他们特别准备投降。只是因为由于种种原因，在最最顶层出现了领导层的失误。它太笨重了。它太官僚了。它太受控制了。但在很短的时间内，斯大林和高级指挥官们
sort of, to a very large extent, get themselves together. They create the Stavka, which is a sort of high command, which Stalin, of course, is still overseeing. But that's put in place. They start massive, massive recruitment. I mean, the interesting thing is, is on the 22nd of June 1941, there are 14 million Soviet people who have already had some form of military training who are in reserves, you know, that can be called up.
在很大程度上，重新振作了起来。他们创建了“最高统帅部”（Stavka），这是一种最高指挥机构，当然斯大林仍然在监督它。但这个机构建立起来了。他们开始大规模、大规模地征兵。我的意思是，有趣的是，在1941年6月22日，有1400万苏联人已经接受了某种形式的军事训练，他们在预备役中，你知道的，可以被征召入伍。
And in 1941, there are three million Soviets who are due to come of age and become 18 that year. Okay, can I ask the obvious question then, which Brian Williams poses? Was victory by Nazi Germany achievable? Or was Barbarossa always doomed to fail? It was only achievable if the Soviet leadership was even more crap than it was. Right. The Germans did not have enough, the right planning or the right thinking to achieve it without the help of the Soviet Union. So let me ask you about the Soviet Union there, because Stalin, the story goes that he gets these phone calls from Zhukov or whoever, sort of the early hours of the morning. People can't get hold of him and he's dumbstruck. Isn't this an amazing story that Zhukov rings him
而在1941年，有300万苏联人即将成年并在当年满18岁。好吧，那我能问一个显而易见的问题吗，也就是布赖恩·威廉姆斯提出的问题：纳粹德国的胜利是可能的吗？还是说巴巴罗萨注定要失败？只有当苏联领导层比当时还要糟糕透顶时，这才是可能的。没错。如果没有苏联的帮助，德国人没有足够的计划或正确的思维来实现这一目标。所以让我问你关于苏联的问题，因为斯大林，据传他接到朱可夫或某个人的电话，大约在清晨。人们联系不上他，他惊呆了。这难道不是一个惊人的故事吗：朱可夫给他打电话，
and Stalin's just kind of panting, breathing very heavily on the other end of the line because he's taken so much unawares. But is this, James, an interesting difference between Stalin and Hitler? Does Stalin basically, does he sort himself out and let his generals take care of it rather than interfere? Or is he still masterminding everything after the initial shock?
而斯大林在电话那头只是大口喘气、呼吸非常沉重，因为他被打得如此措手不及。但詹姆斯，这难道不是斯大林和希特勒之间一个有趣的区别吗？斯大林基本上，他自己调整好了状态，让他的将军们去处理，而不是进行干涉？还是说在最初的震惊之后，他依然在策划一切？
No, he absolutely is not. And that is the reason for the Kursk encirclement, which is completed on the 14th of September, which is the biggest single victory of all, where some 700,000 are captured in one fell swoop. Who wins that? So this is a German victory against the Red Army, but that is the end of it. That is the last one. And that is because Stalin repeatedly ignores
不，他绝对不是。这就是库尔斯克包围圈的原因，该包围圈于9月14日完成，这是所有战役中最大的一次单一胜利，在这次战役中，大约70万人一举被俘。谁赢得了这场胜利？所以这是德军对红军的胜利，但这只是结束。这是最后一次。这是因为斯大林一再无视
the advice first of Zhukov, who warns him on the 29th of July. At the time, Zhukov is chief of staff, so he's the senior guy. He's the equivalent of Keitel or Marshall or General Brook to the British in the war. He's the top military man, and he says,
首先是朱可夫的建议，朱可夫在7月29日警告过他。当时，朱可夫是总参谋长，所以他是最高层的人。他相当于英国在战争中的凯特尔、马歇尔或布鲁克将军。他是顶级军事人物，他说，
you need to abandon Kiev and get the other side of the Dnieper River. And Stalin just goes, no, there's absolutely no way we're going to abandon Kiev, which is the third largest city in the USSR. No way, Jose. And Zhukov says, in that case, I demand that you allow me to resign and give me a posting on the front. And because Stalin's Stalin, he goes, fine, I'll be going. And so he does. And then there are other repeated warners, you know, Karpinos, who is the commander of the Southwestern Front. Front is a group of armies.
你们需要放弃基辅，撤到第聂伯河的另一边。而斯大林却说，不，我们绝对不可能放弃基辅，那是苏联第三大城市。门儿都没有。朱可夫说，既然如此，我要求你允许我辞职，并给我一个前线的主官职位。而因为斯大林是斯大林，他说，好吧，去吧。于是他真的去了。然后还有其他一再发出警告的人，你知道的，西南方面军司令卡尔平诺夫。方面军就是一群集团军。
So, you know, you're talking about a really seriously large amount of men. I mean, I think there's 650,000 men in the Southwestern Front. Kupanov says, you know, as September, August gives way to September, says, you know, I have to be allowed to do this. I have to be allowed to pull back. And Sartre just goes, absolutely not. No way. But by this point, but I'm sort of jumping the gun. So he is imposing himself on one of the lessons of Kiev in 1941,
所以，你知道，你谈论的是数量非常庞大的军队。我的意思是，我认为西南方面军有65万人的兵力。库帕诺夫说，你知道，随着9月到来，8月让位于9月，他说，你知道，我必须被允许这样做。我必须被允许撤退。而萨特却说，绝对不行。门儿都没有。但到了这个时候，不过我有点操之过急了。因此，他在1941年基辅战役的教训之一上强加了自己的意志，
the capture of Kiev, and this is huge, massive encirclement of over 700,000 Red Army troops. It's at that point Stalin does back off and start listening to his commanders and letting the better commanders go forward and go through to the front. And, you know, Zhukov is one of the beneficiaries of that, of course, and listening to them in a way that the absolute opposite happens with Hitler, that Hitler, who demands the Kiev encirclement,
基辅的陷落，这是一个巨大的、大规模的对超过70万红军部队的包围。正是在那个时候，斯大林确实退让了，并开始听取他的指挥官的意见，让更好的指挥官上前线并穿过前线。而且，你知道，朱可夫是其中的受益者之一，当然，倾听他们的意见，这与希特勒的情况完全相反，希特勒要求进行基辅包围圈，
diverts forces away from the strike to Moscow at huge expense, and then goes, told you so, we've had the biggest victory ever. But actually, it's a Pyrrhic victory. Okay, so one of the obvious points in comparison with the Russian invasion of Ukraine is that it was a kind of three-pronged. They didn't just target on us. They didn't have a single target. They dissipated their forces. Is that what the Nazis do? Because they're targeting Leningrad, they're targeting Moscow, and they're targeting Ukraine. Is that right? Yes. So what you've got with the German invasion, you've got
不惜付出巨大代价将部队从对莫斯科的进攻中调离，然后说，我早就告诉过你们了吧，我们取得了有史以来最大的胜利。但实际上，这是一场惨胜。好吧，那么与俄罗斯入侵乌克兰相比，一个显而易见的地方在于，这是一场三管齐下的行动。他们不只是针对我们。他们没有单一的目标。他们分散了他们的兵力。纳粹是这么做的吗？因为他们的目标是列宁格勒，他们的目标是莫斯科，他们的目标是乌克兰。是这样吗？是的。所以德国入侵时，你有
three groups of armies, three army groups, army group north, army group south, army group centre. And army group centre is the biggest. And that's got, you know, three panzer groups to start off with. And that's the one that's targeting Moscow. Yes. And that's Field Marshal Fyodor von Bock is the commander of that. And that is targeting Moscow.
三个集团军群，北方集团军群、南方集团军群、中央集团军群。中央集团军群是最大的。一开始，它有三个装甲集群。那正是以莫斯科为目标的集团军群。是的。陆军元帅费多尔·冯·博克是该集团军群的司令。那就是以莫斯科为目标。
It's going straight for, first of all, you know, that's from Brest in a straight line through what is now belarus to smolensk take smolensk on the 15th of july it's all looking absolutely fantastic but then thereafter it kind of the red army response starts to sort of stiffen yet more men appear and suddenly there's sort of the first of much bigger tanks i won't go go into the details, Dominic, don't worry. But they're bigger. And the Germans haven't seen anything like it. And there just seems to be, it doesn't matter how many they mow down,
它径直朝着目标前进，首先，你知道的，那是从布列斯特出发，穿过现在白俄罗斯的直线直奔斯摩棱斯克，在7月15日占领斯摩棱斯克，一切看起来都绝对棒极了。但在此之后，红军的反应开始变得更加顽强，更多的人出现，突然间出现了第一批大得多的坦克——我不打算谈论细节，多米尼克，别担心。但它们更大了。德国人从未见过这样的东西。而且似乎无论他们割倒多少，
more Red Army troops seem to appear. So it's a bit sort of Hydra's head-like. And while all that is happening, so there is this sort of huge stride across the map to start off with. And then it just completely slows down. And while this is happening, this is when Hitler then suddenly says, actually, let's not worry about Moscow for now. Let's go and take Leningrad in the north and let's go and take Ukraine in the
似乎会出现更多的红军部队。所以它有点像九头蛇的脑袋。正当这一切发生的时候——所以一开始在地图上有一大步的跨越，然后它就完全慢了下来。正当这一切发生的时候，希特勒突然说，其实，我们现在别担心莫斯科了，我们去攻占北部的列宁格勒，去攻占南部的
south. So I'm going to divert lots of troops from army group centre, this group of armies in the centre of the line, and divert them southwards. But you can't just sort of click your fingers and expect that to happen because there are huge supply chains involved. And the other problem is with Panzer Group 2, which is one of these spearheads that I was telling you about, they're groups of divisions. It's like a group of armies in a way of motorised troops.
乌克兰。所以我要把中央集团军群的大量部队——也就是战线中央的这个集团军群——调往南方。但你不能仅仅打个响指就指望这一切发生，因为这涉及巨大的供应链。另一个问题是装甲第2集群——我刚才跟你讲过的这些箭头部队之一，它们是师的集群。在某种程度上，它就像是一群摩托化部队的集团军。
To go southwards is then cutting across the flanks of the Red Army lines. So why is he doing it? Why has he suddenly changed his plans? Because it's all taking a bit longer than he thinks, and he can see that the Red Army is stiffening in Army Group Centre, and because he's suddenly thinking actually the whole point of going here was not to take Moscow,
向南进发就会切断红军防线的侧翼。那他为什么要这么做？他为什么突然改变计划？因为这一切比他想象的要花更长的时间，而且他能看出红军在中央集团军群的抵抗正在变强，而且因为他突然觉得去那里的整个目的其实不是为了占领莫斯科，
it's to get land and territory and resources. It's also oil and stuff, isn't it? And oil, and the further south we are, the closer we are to Baku and Azerbaijan and the Caucasus, which is where all the oil is. I mean, even that is total la-la land because they haven't got any capacity to refine it or indeed transport it. So, James, let's talk about Ukraine specifically because you mentioned earlier on the battle
而是为了获得土地、领土和资源。这也是为了石油之类的东西，对吧？还有石油，我们越往南，我们就越接近巴库、阿塞拜疆和高加索，那里是所有石油所在地。我的意思是，甚至这都是完全的白日梦，因为他们没有任何精炼甚至运输它的能力。所以，詹姆斯，让我们具体谈谈乌克兰，因为你刚才提到了那场战役，
for what we then called and what we called until a few months ago, Kiev. Yes. what we then called and what we called until a few months ago, Kiev. So obviously a lot of the fighting, I mean, then as now, happened in Ukraine. Do the Germans think that the Ukrainians, who of course had fought for their independence, or some of them had at least after the Russian Revolution in the early years of the 1920s, do they think that they will be greeted as liberators? Or do they think, well, the Ukrainians are just yet more Slavs who should be exterminated and all this sort of stuff? I mean, because they seem to have a very confused, shall we say,
我们当时称之为、直到几个月前我们还称之为基辅的城市。是的。我们当时称之为、直到几个月前我们还称之为基辅的城市。所以很显然，大量的战斗——当时和现在一样——都发生在乌克兰。德国人是否认为乌克兰人——他们当然为独立而战过，或者至少其中一些人在20世纪初俄罗斯革命后这样做过——会把他们当作解放者来欢迎？还是说他们认为，好吧，乌克兰人不过是更多的斯拉夫人，应该被消灭，诸如此类？我的意思是，因为他们似乎有一种非常混乱的，我们可以这么说，
nationalities policy where they want to be greeted as liberators, but also they want to exterminate the people who greeted them. Yeah, it's exactly that. And again, you know, none of it stacks up. It's not consistent in any shape or form. But broadly speaking, they could have won over certainly the Western Ukrainians without any problem at all, I'd have thought, for the most part. And they would have had a large number of people who were prepared to fight for them against Stalin. I mean, Ukrainians are no friend of, you know, no friend of Stalin in any shape or form, you know, thanks to millions being starved in the 1930s. So they've got sort of potentially willing people, but no, they're all Slavs in dimension two, and they're impoverished and just sort of,
民族政策：他们希望被当作解放者欢迎，但也想消灭那些欢迎他们的人。是的，正是如此。而且，再次，你知道，所有这些都站不住脚。它在任何形式或形态上都不是一致的。但粗略地说，我认为他们本可以毫无问题地赢得西方乌克兰人的支持，在很大程度上是这样的。他们会拥有一大批准备为他们而战以对抗斯大林的人。我的意思是，乌克兰人在任何形式或形态上都不是斯大林的朋友，你知道的，多亏了20世纪30年代的饥荒导致数百万人饿死。所以他们拥有潜在的自愿追随者，但不，从维度二来看，他们全都是斯拉夫人，他们贫困潦倒，只是一群，
you know, backward peasants and deserve nothing but complete contempt. And so they go around sort of burning, torching villages and sort of anyone who looks sort of vaguely Jewish or a disruptor, they get shot. So does that mean it's not really winning hearts and minds? It's the implication of that though, that with a different, I mean, in some parallel universe where that invasion is being led, not by ideological Nazis,
你知道，落后的农民，只配得到彻底的蔑视。所以他们到处焚烧村庄，任何看起来有点像犹太人或破坏分子的人都会被枪毙。那这是否意味着这并没有真正赢得民心？不过，这意味着，在另一个平行宇宙中，那场入侵不是由意识形态纳粹领导的，
but by German nationalists, sort of World War I type, if you like, Ludendorff types or something. That is the implication of that, that they could have had, the Germans could have had much more success if they had co-opted Ukrainian nationalism. I mean, for one thing...
而是由德国民族主义者领导的——有点像一战那种类型的，如果你喜欢的话，像鲁登道夫类型的人。这就是那层含义，即如果德国人能够将乌克兰民族主义拉拢过来，他们本可以取得更大的成功。我的意思是，首先……
Yes, but they're never going to because the whole war is an ideological war in the first place. So that, you know, the kind of what if just doesn't work with the Nazis. So on that topic, we've got two questions. One from Guillermo de Avaledo. Was the cruelty on the Eastern Front directly derived from Nazi ideology or was it inevitable? So in other words, is the savagery hard-baked? Is it part of the kind of, you know, it was always there?
是的，但他们永远不会这样做，因为这场战争从一开始就是一场意识形态战争。所以，你知道，“如果”这种假设在纳粹身上根本行不通。关于这个话题，我们有两个问题。一个来自吉列尔莫·德·阿瓦雷多。东线战场的残酷是直接源自纳粹意识形态，还是不可避免的？换句话说，这种野蛮是根深蒂固的吗？它是那种你知道的、原本就存在的东西的一部分吗？
Or does it arise from the kind of the horror of the fighting? And then just one other question, which is kind of hanging over this, the whole discussion we've had so far from Dave Rich. What role did Barbarossa play in the escalation of the Holocaust? So specifically with the Jews? It absolutely does, because it is an ideological war. There is this ideological element which is not there in any of the operations in the West, the Blitzkrieg in the West. It's just not there. Whereas it absolutely is a fundamental part of the whole thing you know this is this is to rid the world of bolshevism and you know which is a overseen by a cabal of of world Jewry so so these guys are all utterly contemptible I mean you know when they go into when they go into Ukraine you know the same aforementioned George Thomas is putting together a plan called the hunger plan
还是它源于战斗的残酷性？还有一个问题，这个问题一直悬而决决，贯穿了我们至今为止的所有讨论，来自戴夫·里奇。巴巴罗萨在犹太人大屠杀的升级中扮演了什么角色？具体对犹太人而言？它绝对扮演了，因为这是一场意识形态战争。这里有一个意识形态因素，这是在西方的任何行动中都没有的，西方的闪击战中没有。它就是不存在。然而它绝对是整件事情的一个基础部分，你知道，这是为了将世界从布尔什维克主义中解脱出来，而布尔什维克主义是由一个世界犹太人财阀集团监督的，所以这些家伙全都是极其卑鄙的。我的意思是，你知道，当他们进入——当他们进入乌克兰时，你知道，前面提到的乔治·托马斯正在制定一个名为“饥饿计划”的计划，
where they're basically going to rape um all the food of Ukraine. And they think sort of quite casually that that could probably lead to the deaths of 20 to 30 million people. You know, this is this is not the SS. This is this is the Wehrmacht planning office that's coming up with this plan. I mean, as it happens, you know, Stalin insists on a kind of scorched earth policy anyway. So anything that's useful to the Germans is burnt as they retreat. And anyone who gets in the way of the Germans is also sort of burnt and shot and villages torched and all the rest of it, just because they're sort of in the way
他们基本上要掠夺——乌克兰的所有粮食。他们很随意地认为，这可能会导致2000万到3000万人死亡。你知道，这不是党卫军。这是德意志国防军的计划部门在想出这个计划。碰巧的是，你知道的，斯大林无论如何都坚持焦土政策。所以任何对德国人有用的东西在他们撤退时都被烧毁了。任何挡住德国人去路的人也都被烧死、枪杀，村庄被烧毁，其余的一切也是如此，只因为他们挡了路，
and someone sniped from them. So, you know, they'll just bulldoze a whole lot. I mean, that's how it is. So it just escalates. But it escalates very, very quickly in the USSR and particularly in Ukraine and particularly in the Baltic states, actually, because in March 1941,
而且有人向他们狙击。所以，你知道，他们会直接推平一大片。我的意思是，事情就是这样的。所以它只是在升级。但它在苏联升级得非常非常快，特别是在乌克兰，特别是在波罗的海国家，事实上，因为在1941年3月，
Hitler has briefed all his commanders and basically given them carte blanche to do whatever they like you know this is a this is an ideological war this is a total war it's a war of annihilation you know whatever you do is fine by me and have they been briefed have they been briefed particularly to target the jews yeah of course yeah einsatz gruppen have been put have been have been created specially to follow on behind the lead troops to come in and round them all up and you know of course that's exactly what happens when they do take Kiev they take Kiev is captured on the 19th of September 1941 um there are then some delayed action explosions which have been left by the Red Army some depots which have been mined and booby trapped and they blow up I think
希特勒向他所有的指挥官作了简报，基本上赋予了他们全权，让他们随心所欲，你知道，这是一场意识形态战争，这是一场全面战争，这是一场歼灭战，你知道，无论你做什么我都赞成。而且他们是否得到了简报，是否特别被指示要针对犹太人？是的，当然。别动队（Einsatzgruppen）是专门组建的，用来跟在主力部队后面，进来把他们全抓起来，你知道，当然，当他们确实占领基辅时，事情正是这样发生的。基辅于1941年9月19日沦陷，
on the 22nd and 24th of September something like that um and on the 29th and so so clearly that that that must be jews um and so they're all rounded up and you know 33 771 are executed at babi yar just outside kiev on the 29th and 30th of of of september and himla witnesses this and goes oh that's disgusting it's horrible we can't have our men doing that shooting people he's in a dutch you've got to think of something else which of course leads to you know cyclone Cyclone B and the death camps. Just on a quick question about nationalities. I mean, we talked always about the Germans,
然后发生了一些由红军留下、被布雷和设下诡雷的仓库引发的定时炸弹爆炸，它们炸毁了，我想在9月22日和24日左右，诸如此类。然后在9月29日，显然这一定是犹太人干的，所以他们都被抓了起来，你知道，33771人在基辅郊外的娘子谷（Babi Yar）被处决，时间是9月29日和30日。希姆莱目睹了这一幕，并说：“哦，这太恶心了，太可怕了，我们不能让我们的手下做那种事，去枪杀人。”他在一个公函中说：你必须想别的办法。这当然导致了——你知道的——齐克隆B（Zyklon B）和死亡集中营。关于民族，有一个简短的问题。我的意思是，我们总是谈论德国人，
but obviously it's not just a German operation, right? There are Romanians, Finns, Italians, Hungarians, and Slovakians. Are they,
但很显然这不仅是一场德国人的行动，对吧？还有罗马尼亚人、芬兰人、意大利人、匈牙利人和斯洛伐克人。他们是，
are they million adjunct or are they a key part of that? Okay. They're a million adjunct. They're in our army group South. And because they're so bad, badly trained, they're given so utter, nothing but utter contempt by the Germans, they don't really help Army South's progress.
他们是无足轻重的附属，还是其中的关键部分？好吧。他们是无足轻重的附属。他们在我们的南方集团军群里。而且因为他们太糟糕了，训练不足，他们受到德国人的绝对蔑视，一无可取，他们对南方集团军群的进展并没有真正起到什么帮助。
So you've got these three prongs, these three groups of armies. You've got Army Group North, which is going into the Baltic, clearing out the Baltic, and then pushing on towards Leningrad after Hitler changes his mind. You've got Army Group Centre, which, as you remember I was saying, was the biggest, strongest one. Then you've got Army Group South, which is commanded by von Wundstedt, who's the commander of Army Group A in the Western, in the Battle of France and the Low Countries and everything in 1940.
所以你有这三个箭头，这三个集团军群。你有北方集团军群，它进入波罗的海，清除波罗的海，然后在希特勒改变主意后向列宁格勒推进。你有中央集团军群，正如你记得我刚才说的，它是最大、最强的。然后你有南方集团军群，由冯·伦德施泰特指挥，他曾在1940年法国战役和低地国家战役等行动中担任A集团军群司令。
So he's sort of a big cheese. And where Army Group South is really struggling is, first of all, their allies are useless and rubbish and ill-trained and ill-equipped and not very good. And the second problem is these huge distances. I mean, these vast, vast distances. So one of the other assumptions of Barbarossa is that what they'll do is they'll just capture Soviet rail stock, and then they'll just use it for their own purposes. But of course, the Soviets just destroy them all. Either take them back with them, or if they can't, they destroy them before the Germans can get their hands on them. There's a whole host of problems with this. The first problem is that Soviet loading gauge is wider than that of the German and European loading gauge. So the Germans then have to use their own locomotives and their own rolling stock. But as they move forward into the Soviet Union, they've then got to narrow the gauge.
所以他算是个大人物。南方集团军群真正挣扎的地方在于，首先，他们的盟友毫无用处、烂透了、训练不足、装备落后、表现不佳。第二个问题是这些巨大的距离。我的意思是，这些浩瀚、浩瀚的距离。所以巴巴罗萨的另一个假设是，他们将要做的是直接俘获苏联的铁路机车车辆，然后直接为他们自己的目的使用它们。但当然，苏联人把它们全毁了。要么把它们带走，要么如果带不走，就在德国人下手之前把它们毁掉。这里有大量的问题。第一个问题是，苏联的轨道轨距比德国和欧洲的轨距要宽。所以德国人随后必须使用他们自己的机车和他们自己的铁路车辆。但当他们向苏联境内推进时，他们随后必须缩小轨距。
So every single bit of rail has to be moved, you know, a couple of inches to the left or whatever. You imagine how long that takes and that takes? The second problem is that Soviet locomotives are bigger and they can go further with less refuelling of coal and water. So the Germans, their Kriegsloch, which is their sort of standard train, they then have to put in more coal stops and more water stops as well as narrowing the gauge to get anywhere. And you can imagine i mean this this is this is not conducive to speed and it's just a total misappreciation and it's
所以每一段铁轨都必须向左移动几英寸或诸如此类。你能想象这需要多长时间吗？第二个问题是，苏联的机车更大，它们可以用更少的煤炭和水补给行驶得更远。所以德国人，他们的克里格斯洛克（Kriegslok），也就是他们的标准列车，随后必须投入更多的燃煤站和更多的加水站，还要缩小轨距才能到达任何地方。你可以想象——我的意思是，这——这不利于速度，这完全是误判，而且这也是
also a problem isn't it which i i know from listening to the um two excellent episodes you did on on the planning for barbara on we have ways that um there are no petrol stations well they're wrong i mean so in france when they invade there are no petrol stations. Well, there are. So in France, when they invade, there are petrol stations conveniently situated for all the tanks to fill up or whatever. But in Russia, there are no petrol stations. There are none. I mean, as I said,
一个问题，对吧？我知道，从听你为“我们有办法”节目制作的关于巴巴罗萨计划的那两集精彩节目中，我了解到——那里没有加油站。好吧，他们错了，我的意思是——所以在法国，当他们入侵时，没有加油站。好吧，有的。所以在法国，当他们入侵时，有很方便的加油站供所有坦克加油或做别的什么。但在俄罗斯，没有加油站。一个也没有。我的意思是，正如我所说，
France was the most automotive nation in Europe. So of course there's lots of petrol stations and workshops and all the rest of it. Those do not exist. Yeah. And Germany is very, very under-mechanized as well. So they've got double the problems because they don't have enough mechanics they don't have enough people in there
法国是欧洲汽车化程度最高的国家。所以当然有很多加油站、修理厂和其余的一切。那些根本不存在。是的。而且德国的机械化程度也极其、极其低下。所以他们面临着双倍的问题，因为他们没有足够的机械师，他们没有足够的人手，
they just don't have enough spanners and you know all the rest of it i mean the just it's just the whole thing is this sort of spiraling the military term for this is the culmination point the culmination point is the point where you can no longer operate in the way you want to operate because your your lines of supply are just too long. And your lines of supply become so long that half your capacity is spent feeding the line of supply rather than the people at the front. And to put this just sort of where it's already going drastically wrong in July, despite Smolensk falling on the 15th of July, despite these huge, huge gains and
他们只是没有足够的扳手，你知道的，其余的一切。我的意思是，整个事情就是这样一种螺旋式上升——对此的军事术语是“顶点”（the culmination point）。顶点是指你无法再以你想要的方式作战的那个点，因为你的补给线太长了。你的补给线变得如此之长，以至于你的一半产能都花在了维持补给线上，而不是供给前线的人。为了说明在7月份事情就已经急转直下到什么地步，尽管斯摩棱斯克在7月15日陷落，尽管取得了这些巨大、巨大的战果和
750,000 Soviet prisoners or whatever the figure is. One panzer division is down to 12 tanks by the 18th of July. And the whole of Panzer Group 2, which is the single largest panzer group, that is the absolute creme de la creme this is all the kind of 20 to 30 year olds this is all the fully trained people this is all your sparkly tanks and and bmw sidecars and half tracks and armor cars and all the rest of it they are down to 29 percent of the tanks that they started off with on the 22nd of june it's completely unsustainable so my point is that even if they'd gone in a month earlier, it's not the time that's the problem.
75万苏联战俘或无论具体数字是多少。到7月18日，一个装甲师只剩下12辆坦克。整个装甲第2集群——这是最大单一装甲集群，这绝对是精锐中的精锐，这全都是20到30岁的小伙子，这全都是受过全面训练的人，这全都是你那些闪闪发光的坦克、宝马摩托车挎斗、半履带车和装甲车以及其余的一切——到6月22日开始时，他们的坦克数量只剩下最初的29%。这完全是不可持续的。所以我的观点是，即使他们提前一个月进攻，时间也不是问题所在。
It's the expanse and the Soviet response to this. You know, the value of a German soldier is just far greater to the Germans than the value of a Soviet soldier is to the German. Because of the manpower. But James, isn't it also the case, though, that wars are won not just by logistics, but they're also won by politics?
问题在于广袤的幅员和苏联对此的反应。你知道，对德国人来说，一个德国士兵的价值远大于一个苏联士兵对德国人的价值。因为人力资源。但是詹姆斯，难道不是吗，战争的胜利不仅靠后勤，也靠政治？
And that one of the Germans' big mistakes is they underestimate Russian patriotism. They underestimate their will to fight. They underestimate the... Because they think communists are wretched and deluded. They underestimate the resilience of the of the soviet machine i suppose so even if they take and let's say they let's say they'd encircled moscow you know you're going to probably say that was on you know unimaginable anyway but let's say
而德国人的重大错误之一是他们低估了俄罗斯的爱国主义。他们低估了俄罗斯人的战斗意志。他们低估了……因为他们认为共产主义者是可悲和受蒙蔽的。我想他们低估了苏联机器的韧性。所以即使他们攻占了——假设他们——假设他们包围了莫斯科——你可能会说这无论如何是不可想象的——但假设
they'd done that let's say they'd fought their way into the center of moscow as napoleon did of course would that have brought them victory or what was russia was the soviet union always too resilient politically to fall i think so i think there are moments there's a moment in october 1941 where there is sort of mass panic in moscow there was obviously moment in the opening days of barbara rossa where where it's looking bare-brained i mean you know stalin absolutely does not help himself by insisting on um keeping kiev and and keeping the southwestern front up at the denipa when clearly it was going to be encircled so the idea of the encirclement from the german point of view was that this this panzer group two comes down from you know from the slovensk area
他们做到了，假设他们像拿破仑那样一路杀进莫斯科市中心，这会给他们带来胜利吗？还是说俄罗斯、苏联在政治上始终具有太强的韧性而不会倒台？我想是的。我想有过这样的时刻：1941年10月，莫斯科陷入了某种大规模恐慌；在巴巴罗萨开始的头几天，显然也有过那种情况，当时看起来毫无理智。我的意思是，你知道，斯大林绝对是在帮倒忙，他坚持要
down southwards through bella what is now belarus into into, but east of the Dnieper River. And Panzer Group 1, which is part of Army Group South, going south of Kiev, pulling up to getting a bridgehead over Dnieper, near Dnieper-Bretovsk, would then swirl northwards. And so they come down and meet each other. And there's this huge pocket of a circle in the middle of which Kiev is caught in the middle of it. And this is a very familiar from what's going on in Ukraine at the moment. That actually it's quite difficult to coordinate these kind of... It really is.
守住基辅，并在第聂伯河上维持西南方面军，而当时它显然会被包围。所以从德国人的角度来看，包围的想法是：这个装甲第2集群从（你知道的）斯摩棱斯克地区向南推进，穿过白俄罗斯（现在是白俄罗斯），进入——但在第聂伯河以东。而属于南方集团军群一部分的装甲第1集群，在基辅以南推进，推进到一个位于第聂伯罗彼得罗夫斯克附近的第聂伯河桥头堡，然后会向北盘旋。于是它们南下并会师。中间有一个巨大的包围圈，基辅正好被夹在中间。这与目前乌克兰正在发生的事情非常相似。实际上，协调这类……真的很困难。
And the point is that Army Group 2, Panzer Group 2 particularly, is absolutely on its knees by the time of the join up. So it looks like an amazing victory for the Germans. And it is, in terms of the amount of men they captured and the kind of disaster for the Red Army. But they've been so chewed up in the whole process that they're on their knees. And at that point, Hitler's also saying just a few days
关键在于，装甲第2集群，特别是装甲第2集群，在会师时已经完全精疲力竭了。所以对德国人来说，这看起来像是一场惊人的胜利。就他们俘虏的人数以及对红军的灾难而言，确实如此。但在整个过程中，他们已经被消耗得精疲力竭，以至于跪倒在地了。就在那时，希特勒还在几天前——就在
before the actual meetup the join-up actually happens on the evening of the 14th of september so about 6 20 p.m just north of a um just south of a north of a little place called lubny which incidentally is is fanatically defended by civilians and um nkvb nkvd people which are obviously former kgb um uh with people chucking molotov cocktails and firing from the rooftops at these panzers. But they still, you know, Lubny Falls, when this join-up actually happens, just. But at the same time, Hitler's going, okay,
实际会师发生前的几天——会师实际上发生在9月14日傍晚，大约下午6点20分，就在一个名为卢布尼（Lubny）的小地方以北、以南——顺便说一句，这个地方遭到平民以及内务人民委员部（NKVD）人员（也就是前克格勃）的狂热抵抗，人们向这些坦克投掷莫洛托夫鸡尾酒（燃烧瓶）并从屋顶开火。但他们还是，你知道的，卢布尼陷落了，当这次会师真正发生时，勉强成功了。但与此同时，希特勒却在说，好吧，
Barbarossa hasn't completely won, so we need a new operation, which is going to be Operation Typhoon, and that is going to be back again towards Moscow. So everyone's sort of going, but we were going to Moscow and you've just diverted us all down and we haven't got Leningrad. And okay, we have got this massive encirclement, but all the encirclement is telling
巴巴罗萨并没有完全赢得胜利，所以我们需要一个新的行动，那就是“台风行动”（Operation Typhoon），它将再次指向莫斯科。所以每个人都在说，但我们本来是要去莫斯科的，你却把我们全都调到了南部，而且我们还没有拿下列宁格勒。好吧，我们确实取得了这个巨大的包围圈，但所有的包围圈都在向
a lot of the people on the ground is the absolute infinitesimal reserves of the Red Army because they're still in the game. They've still got an air force. They've still got guns. They've still got more men to come. You know, they've still got these,
地面的许多人说明红军拥有绝对无限的预备队，因为他们仍然在局中。他们仍然有一支空军。他们仍然有枪支。他们仍然有更多的人员到来。你知道，他们仍然有这些，
they've still got 14 million people they can call up. They've still got an air force. They've still got guns. They've still got more men to come. You know, they've still got they've still got 14 million people they can call up. They've still got three million people of the 18 year old age group, et cetera, et cetera. So it's sort of for Hitler. Kiev is is an endorsement of his military genius. You know, everyone everyone thought he was wrong in 1940 and he proved them right. He proved his commanders wrong. The numbskulls, these Prussian elites. And everyone said, fear, I don't think it's a good idea to sort of divert from Moscow, go into Leningrad and Kiev. And he's like, I told you so. Look at that. It's the biggest victory ever in the history of the world. He still feels the need, though. He does have the sense that it hasn't gone well
他们仍然有1400万可以征召的人口。他们仍然有一支空军。他们仍然有枪支。他们仍然有更多的人员到来。你知道，他们仍然有——他们仍然有1400万可以征召的人口。他们仍然有300万18岁年龄段的人口，等等，等等。所以对希特勒来说，基辅是对他军事天才的肯定。你知道，每个人——每个人在1940年都认为他是错的，而他证明了自己是对的。他证明了他的指挥官们是错的。那些笨蛋，这些普鲁士精英。当时每个人都说：“元首，我认为从莫斯科分兵去列宁格勒和基辅不是个好主意。”而他却说：“我早就告诉过你们了吧。看看那个。这是世界历史上最大的胜利。”不过，他仍然觉得有必要。他确实有一种感觉，即事情进展得还不够顺利，他们需要一个新的行动。所以实际上，这也是巴巴罗萨行动的结束。是的，这就是关键所在。它就在基辅。基辅在某种程度上是一场了不起的胜利。但在另一方面，他们是在把自己赢得精疲力竭。这就是重点。那是在大雪落下之前。那是在他们到达莫斯科之前。
enough, that they need a new operation. So effectively, this is also the end of Operation Barbarossa. Yes, and that's the point. It is at Kiev. Kiev is a terrific victory on one level. But on another level, they're winning themselves to death. That's the point. That is before the snow falls. That is before they've got to Moscow.
足够了，以至于他们需要进行一次新的行动。所以实际上，这也是“巴巴罗萨行动”的结束。是的，这就是关键所在。它发生在基辅。基辅在某种程度上是一场巨大的胜利。但在另一个层面上，他们正通过不断取胜走向毁灭。这就是关键。那是大雪降临之前。那是他们到达莫斯科之前。
They're all there. Here's the question, though. So from the picture you painted, the Germans have lost this colossal gamble within months, weeks of making it. But then they're exhausted. There's some group, whatever, panzers are on their knees, all this stuff. So my question would be, why does it take so long then for them to be beaten? Because they're going to be in Russia for years. I mean, they're fighting in Stalingrad,
他们全都在那里。不过，问题来了：从你描绘的图景来看，德国人在发起这场豪赌后的几个月、几周内就已经输掉了这场巨大的赌局。但接着他们筋疲力尽了。有些集群，无论哪个，装甲部队都精疲力竭了，所有这些东西。所以我的问题是，为什么他们被击败还要花这么长时间？因为他们将在俄罗斯待上好几年。我的意思是，他们在斯大林格勒作战，
they're fighting these colossal tank battles a couple of years later. How is it that they are so resilient if the operation is so misconceived? Yeah, that's a really good question. So the Germans do press on Operation Typhoon. It is incredible what they managed to amass for that attack. And it's all based around, you know, Army Group Centre again. So replacement tanks have come up and so on. They're still a fraction of what they were on June 19, you know, the start of Operation Barbarossa.
几年后他们还在进行这些巨大的坦克战。如果这项行动从一开始就如此构想失误，他们怎么能有这么强的韧性？是的，这是一个非常好的问题。所以德国人确实在推进“台风行动”。他们为那次进攻设法集结的力量是令人难以置信的。而且这一切基本上还是围绕着中央集团军群。因此，替代坦克已经运到等等。它们仍然只是19月（6月19日，巴巴罗萨行动开始时）的一小部分。
But they do manage to have a sort of a concentration of force to a certain extent by stripping from Army Group north from stripping from army group south and putting all their eggs in one basket of army group center to be you know that is how operation typhoon is is able to to happen and and that happened that they get any success at all is largely because of the encirclement of kiev which is almost entirely down to the incompetence of stalin i mean you know that is 700,000 people that do not need to be in the bag and are there purely because of Stalin's incompetence. It's about who is the least incompetent dictator here. Well, that certainly plays a part. But the reason it goes on,
但他们确实通过从北方集团军群抽调、从南方集团军群抽调，把所有的鸡蛋放在中央集团军群这一个篮子里，在某种程度上成功地实现了兵力集中——你知道，这就是“台风行动”得以实现的方式。他们之所以能取得任何成功，很大程度上是因为基辅包围圈，这几乎完全归咎于斯大林的无能。我的意思是，你知道，那有70万人根本不需要落入网套，之所以在那里纯粹是因为斯大林的无能。这完全取决于谁是这里最不无能的独裁者。嗯，这当然起到了一部分作用。但它之所以持续下去，
so then they get counterattacked quite heavily opposite Moscow in early December 1941. But then both sides sort of run out of steam and it's winter. And so there's a sort of cooling off period in the front. You know, the snow's on the ground and nothing really happens for a while. And everyone's aware that, you know, what's going to happen in the following summer is going to be another renewed offensive by Germany. And of course, you know, between December and late July 1941, Germany's had a chance to build up its strength and all the rest of it.
所以在1941年12月初，他们在莫斯科对面遭到了一次相当猛烈的反击。但随后双方都有些筋疲力尽，而且冬天到了。因此前线进入了一段相对冷却的时期。你知道，地上积满了雪，有一段时间确实什么也没发生。每个人都很清楚，你知道的，接下来夏天将要发生的事情将是德国发起的又一次全新攻势。当然，你知道的，在1941年12月到7月下旬之间，德国有机会积蓄力量，诸如此类。
Soviet Union's had a chance to kind of get its factories that it's moved to the Urals back into gear, more T-34 tanks and all the rest of it. And they're blocking, you know, they're making Moscow absolutely impenetrable, which they do. But Case Blue, which is the operation in the summer of 1942, is driven towards the Caucasus. But by this point, it's no in the summer of 1942, is driven towards the Caucasus. But by this point, it's no longer Operation Barbarossa, right? No, Operation Barbarossa ends on the 25th of September 1941. So that being so, and this episode being about Operation Barbarossa.
苏联有机会让那些搬到乌拉尔山的工厂重新运转起来，生产出更多T-34坦克以及诸如此类。他们在阻挡，你知道的，他们把莫斯科打造成了绝对坚不可摧的堡垒，而他们也确实做到了。但是“蓝色方案”，也就是1942年夏天的行动，其矛头直指高加索。但到了这个时候，在1942年的夏天，这不再是“巴巴罗萨行动”了，对吗？不对，“巴巴罗萨行动”在1941年9月25日就结束了。既然如此，鉴于本集的主题是“巴巴罗萨行动”。
It's time to go on a quiz. Could I just, before we end, one last question, which I think is a great question. I've always wondered, and it's asked by Nick Rogers, and Dominic mentioned Napoleon and Napoleon reaching Moscow. And he asked, did Hitler or his generals at any point study Napoleon's Russian campaign and attempt to draw lessons from it? They did study it, but they thought that was then and this is now and we've got lots of tanks. Okay. Good answer.
是时候进行一个小测验了。在我结束之前，我能问最后一个问题吗？我认为这是一个非常棒的问题。我一直很好奇，这个问题由尼克·罗杰斯提出，多米尼克提到了拿破仑以及拿破仑抵达莫斯科的事。他问，希特勒或他的将领们在任何时候是否研究过拿破仑的俄国战役并试图从中汲取教训？他们确实研究过，但他们认为那是过去，现在是现在，而且我们有很多坦克。好的。回答得好。
Okay, that's fair enough. Bro, thanks ever so much. Now, if you have listened to this and enjoyed it and want to know in absolutely microscopic detail, more about operation Barbarossa about the second world war, about every conceivable aspect of it, there are two episodes that you've done. You've put out, uh, about a month ago on the planning for operation Barbarossa, which are fabulous. And if you haven't listened to them, go check them out. All the other episodes as well. And am I right in thinking that you also have a We Have Ways Fest coming up?
好吧，这倒也合情合理。老兄，太谢谢你了。现在，如果你听了这个节目并且很喜欢，想要了解关于巴巴罗萨行动、关于第二次世界大战、关于其中每一个可以想象的方面的绝对细致入微的细节，那么大约一个月前你们发布了两期关于巴巴罗萨行动策划的节目，它们棒极了。如果你还没听过，去听听看吧。还有所有其他的节目。我没记错的话，你们还有一个“我们自有妙计”音乐节（We Have Ways Fest）要举办吧？
You are absolutely correct, bro. On the 22nd to the 24th of July. So it's for anyone who does listen to We Have Ways Pod, then lots of your friends of the show, lots of historians. We've got historians coming from America, from Canada, from Germany, Austria, Poland. Lots and lots of trucks and hardware. Dominic, it's your summer holiday. Sort it out. Is this the thing that happens in Bicester? Does it happen in Bicester?
你说得完全正确，老兄。就在7月22日到24日。所以对于所有收听“我们自有妙计”播客的人来说，节目里会有你们的很多老朋友，很多历史学家。我们将迎来来自美国、加拿大、德国、奥地利、波兰的历史学家。还有许许多多的卡车和重型装备。多米尼克，这是你的暑假。搞定它。这是在比斯特（Bicester）举办的活动吗？它是在比斯特举办的吗？
The Silverstone Race Circuit is a place called Black Pit Brewery. And it's a splendid place and it's a lot of fun. And you can find out more on wehavewaysfest.co.uk. Brilliant. Wehavewaysfest.co.uk. And we will actually be returning, Tom, to this issue when we're later in the summer when we will be doing a podcast with Ian McGregor, who's got a new book coming out this summer about Stalingrad.
银石赛车场有一个叫做“黑坑啤酒厂”的地方。那是个极好的地方，非常有趣。你可以在 wehavewaysfest.co.uk 上了解更多信息。太棒了。wehaveways.co.uk。汤姆，实际上我们将在今年夏末回到这个话题，届时我们将与伊恩·麦格雷戈一起制作一期播客，他今年夏天将出版一本关于斯大林格勒的新书。
Which is terrific, by the way. It's a very, very good book. Oh, so it's got an endorsement from a top World War II historian, or Second World War historian, I should say. Because you ban the phrase World War II on We Have Ways, don't you? We're British, aren't we?
顺便说一句，这本书非常棒。这是一本非常非常好的书。哦，所以它得到了顶级二战历史学家——或者说第二次世界大战历史学家的背书。因为你们在“我们自有妙计”节目里禁用了“世界大战二”这个词，对吧？我们是英国人，不是吗？
Right. So, on that bombshell, we will see you next time for some more trucks goodbye bye-bye thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes access, ad-free listening and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde.
好啦，伴随着这个重磅消息，我们下次再见，去聊聊更多的卡车。再见，拜拜。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》（The Rest is History）。想要获取独家幕后剧集、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的其余部分》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你获取娱乐新闻、评论和八卦猛料的每周必听节目。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想享受无广告收听、独家剧集和抢先体验……本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。